he has so much credibility I think  probably more credibility than anyone  but he gets it you know he's seen more  fights than anyone he knows how hard it  is to knock someone down like Anderson  Silva how hard it is to knock out Tyrone  Woodley he's basically said if I wasn't  a YouTube kid and I was just a young  boxing Prospect beating all of these  people everyone would be like what the  [ __ ] but for some reason they just say  oh it's fake fights are rigged and I  even see people say oh Jake is paying  Joe Rogan to say this how important is  it to win over people like a Joe Rogan  or others with big audiences that  understand the game of fighting it means  a lot and it's needed for sure